good job do all I want whenever I try to
imitate Arnold Schwarzenegger I just end
up going wah I'm sorry sorry Total
Recall is a film that I've been curious
about because I'm a huge fan of the
original movie Arnold Schwarzenegger I
grew up with it you know it's from 1990
it was in that time when I just saw
these awesome movies and it was it was
in this strange time where you could be
super corny in an action movie and
somehow get away with it
Schwarzenegger is one of the only people
on the face of this earth that can do
that I don't know why it just it works
for him now in the credits it says this
is based off of philip k dick story not
the original film so they're saying it's
not really a remake but I mean it's a
remake everyone's gonna think it's a
remake what no matter what they say if
you've seen the original film you know
the story this guy Colin Farrell goes to
this place called recall he wants to
have them in plant memories in his mind
because he thinks his life is boring he
has a smokin hot wife Kate Beckinsale
but he keeps having these weird dreams
he of this strange past life and he
wants to go to this place so he can get
some fun memories to think of the thing
a you know what once I was a secret
agent similar to the first movie as soon
as he gets hooked up to this machine
some guys come in and take over he takes
all of them down like Bourne Identity
style where suddenly he just has all
these moves and he has no idea why after
that he's on the run from Copenhagen
played by Brian I'm in everything
nowadays Cranston and Kate Beckinsale
his wife who's suddenly this incredibly
menacing villain he meets up with
Jessica Biel another smokin hot babe and
apparently they've had some kind of past
life together - he's trying to piece all
this together wells running and chasing
and shooting and flying from everything
now I heard a lot of bad things from
critics going into this movie and I was
taking it all kind of with a grain of
salt because lately people tend to
really get upset at remakes because they
think it in some way is going to ruin
the original film I don't really buy
into that if you love the original film
it's there it's it's there you know
you're gonna have it forever it's not
gonna change even if you don't like this
movie actually had a lot of fun with
Total Recall and I'm saying that from
perspective of a fan of the original
movie I love that film is this as good
as that original film no no I don't
really like to compare movies that much
but for this movie it really feels like
you kind of have to certain things about
this movie actually work better than the
first film the first one has like this
great nostalgic feel Arnold
Schwarzenegger just has a lot of charm
to him as an act
in this movie doesn't have that even
though I really like Colin Farrell and
he does a good job in this movie and I
like him in this type of film this is
kind of like Minority Report in a lot of
ways and that also had Colin Farrell
there's even a scene where he's like
clamoring on top of this motorized car
that's floating above air there's all
these cars going by really reminded me
of Minority Report I wouldn't exactly go
as far as to say it's copying off of it
but it reminded me of minority ports all
I'm saying one of the things that
definitely worked better in this movie
was the character of the fake wife Kate
Beckinsale Denis originally was Sharon
Stone when she fought Arnold in the
original it looked like she was doing
like an aerobics routine of some kind in
this movie Kate Beckinsale was actually
a convincing menacing villainous
presence
I bought the fact that she could totally
beat up Colin Farrell and basically
everyone else in the movie and she does
really Brian Cranston as Copenhagen I
liked more than the actor who played
Copenhagen in the original film I
thought he did a really good job in this
movie even though he seems to just be
popping up in everything nowadays and
like I said Colin Farrell's a good actor
but he's just not Arnold Schwarzenegger
and he's not trying to be and that's one
of the things I liked about this movie
even though there are certain aspects
that are similar to the original film
they respected it they didn't try to
copy off of it they didn't try to make
Colin Farrell's say all of sports
niggers famous lines can sit up at the
boss my Arnold Schwarzenegger is an
atrocity to mankind
I apologize no one of the things
that I really thought was impressive
about this movie was the action
sequences and I'm not just saying like
oh they were fun and cool to look at
this movies directed by Len Wiseman
movies I've seen if his are the first
underworld and then die hard for or live
for your die hard I can really tell this
guy is an old-school director because he
does a ton of in-camera stunt work
practical stunt work Underworld had it
die hard for had it and this film has it
even though most of the backgrounds and
the ships and everything that's all CGI
the actual stunt work is largely done by
stunt men which makes it more
entertaining to watch the action scenes
are comprehensively filmed there's no
shaky-cam they're well choreographed and
there's a lot of them and it really
honestly made the movie a lot of fun for
me and I was very surprised by that also
another thing backing up the fact this
guy is an old-school director is this
film isn't post converted in some crappy
3d or something it's in 2d and all of
that being said this movie definitely
has problems namely the script one of
the writers is Kurt Wimmer take a glance
at his filmography and you'll see all
different types of garbage now I know
you're ready to say that he made
Librium I'm aware that I don't find that
film amazing I think it was okay
he also made ultraviolet starring Milla
Jovovich one of the worst movies I've
ever seen in my life he's not the
greatest writer on earth that's all I'm
saying and the plot even though I'm
familiar with the original story by
philip k dick and the original film was
kind of incomprehensible at times the
plot honestly was a little bit jumbled
and there was times when I was having a
hard time following it and I shouldn't
feel that way since I'm so versed in the
lore of this movie character motivations
are odd sometimes things just kind of
fall by the wayside of really impressive
action sequences and that was really my
biggest flaw with this movie was the
script some of the plot it didn't really
mesh all the time it seemed sometimes
like characters are something thrown
into this humongous scene of great
action with nothing really to branch
into that it was just really good action
sequences but I can't deny the fact that
I was entertained by this movie I was
never bored with it Colin Farrell did a
good job with his role so did Kate
Beckinsale and honestly even though I'm
not the biggest Jessica Biel fan besides
that but of hers that I would love to
yes I am a horny man what can I say I
apologize for being normal
she was actually good in this movie and
I'm not always that convinced by her
performances she did a good job here
Bryan Cranston was good in this movie
the fight scenes were well filmed well
choreographed there was a lot of action
I like futuristic science-fiction movies
like this and this movie was better than
I thought it would be and I think it's a
lot better than most critics are saying
it is I'm gonna give Total Recall a B
you get a chance to see it I would see
it don't expect it to be better than the
original no shoot thanks a lot for
watching my review guys once you've seen
the movie let me know how you feel about
how the critics are responding to this
movie and how you actually felt about
the movie whatever your thoughts are
whatever your opinions let me know and
as always guys if you like this review
you can subscribe to my channel and get
stuck my nice